there's a new mobile app this is true
that's being referred to as tinder for
cows or cattle yeah this is true
tinder for cows it's official name is
stutter yeah yes this is real and think
about it it was designed to help farmers
find breeding matches for their cattle
which makes sense right
so I thought okay well I guess that's
that's an is something it's necessary
then we looked into it some of the
profiles are pretty interesting
check them out Courtney my milk
literally brings a boy to the yard
yeah there's Samantha utters for days
[Applause]
there's Matthew recently divorced just
looking for fun there's Jeremy looking
for a strong fit horse who can keep a
secret
there's Trevor yes the carpet matches
the drapes hope you're okay with a lot
of carpet Herbert looking for someone
who doesn't die when I'm out her Pablo
antelope who's cow curious
nice I don't want to put my face on here
so if you're serious message me on
Instagram finally Clive hey beautiful
and no those ain't truck nuts
[Music]
[Applause]